in this course you will learn how to
create a custom blog website without any
code using Wordpress I'm Beau with
freecodecamp.org I've created a few
popular WordPress courses and this one
is specifically focused on creating a
Blog but you can use what you learn in
this video to create other types of
websites including business websites
e-commerce sites portfolios and more you
don't need any prior experience to
follow along I'll teach you how to use a
drag and drop system that allows for
easy and Limitless customization so you
can build the perfect website for your
needs and the website will look great on
both desktop and mobile every website
needs a domain name and hosting the
domain is what people type into a
browser such as freecocap.org
youtube.com or Wikipedia.org hosting is
where the files for your website are
actually stored we'll be getting both
the domain name and hosting at
hostinger.com but you can still follow
along if you use a different hosting
provider just use the timestamps in the
description to skip to what you want to
learn hostinger provided a grant that
made this course possible but I had
already used hostinger personally in the
past and had a good experience hostinger
is optimized for WordPress sites and has
a 99.9 uptime guarantee they also give
you a free domain and free SSL so we can
just go here get click get started and
then you can decide whether you're going
to create a brand new website or
transfer an existing website well we're
creating a brand new website and you can
you don't have to go through all this
but we are doing a WordPress here
and I'm just going to
go through here and it'll tell you what
kind of package we want to do so
we can just skip this for now because
this is actually an upgrade but we don't
want to upgrade so I'll just go to skip
here
and then it's going to recommend the
premium shared hosting plan so you can
actually go and just select your plan
manually but this will help you figure
out the exact plan you want you can see
right here you can actually host a
hundred different websites on this plan
and you get a good amount of storage and
you get unlimited bandwidth so that's
pretty good you includes a free domain
and then SSL will make it so you have a
secure website so this is a good option
so I'm just going to select that
and then it's going to show where you
can actually upgrade if you want or you
you can choose a different amount of
months and you can see depending on how
many months you buy at a time is is how
much it's going to renew for so you can
see this one renews at 699 799-899 or
11.99 a month so just pick whatever one
you think is going to work best for you
if you're just testing it out you could
just do a the one month plan or if you
know you're going to have a website long
term you can do one of these other plans
and then
um after you get all this set up you can
go through just to create account and
you can select your payment and then you
can submit it so I'm not actually going
to type in everything but it's pretty
straightforward if you're going to
create your own account for the first
time
so after you get logged in and possibly
as part of creating your account you're
going to want to get your domain so if
you're done creating your account and
you haven't gotten a domain through that
process yet we can just click on claim
domain right in the main menu now here
is you're going to have to have a domain
name that's never been used before it
could take you a few tries to find one
that's not already taken but I'm going
to go with
b-e-a-u with the dashes that's my name
bo but my name doesn't have dashes but
o.net let's check availability
and I already tested this so I knew it
knew it would work and I will claim
domain
okay now we have to set up this domain
registration details
and then we'll just finish filling this
out
okay the domain is registered
okay now add the website to the hosting
plan
and I already had this hosting planned
registered for this other website so
I'll select that one
website connected successfully
now I'll show you how to set up an email
account on your domain through hostinger
so I'm on the hostinger Home tab after
I'm logged in and I'm going to just
click emails
and now I'm going to so I already set up
this one before but now I'm going to set
up the email on the domain we just
created so I'm just going to click there
and then create email account
and then I'm just going to
type in it it automatically filled in
something but I can type in anything I
want so I'm going to put bow and then
I'm just going to type in a password
Here
and then create
okay so now people can email me at bow
at
b-e-a-dash u.net and then I can access
the email by still being on this email
tab here and going to webmail
and then I'll just sign in here
and there are no messages but I can
always compose a new message here and
then I'll receive messages if someone
sends me a message
and now let's go over how to set up SSL
for the website so I'm going to go to
the SSL tab on this hostinger dashboard
and SSL is important it makes sure all
data coming and going from your website
is secure and nobody's going to be able
to there won't be any hackers or anybody
that can see what's going on with the
website if someone submits information
it'll be secure nobody will be able to
see what that information is so I'm just
going to click the install SSL button
and then I'm going to select the website
and just click install SSL and the great
thing is that it's it's free it's
completely included within hosting or
within the plan and now I should have
SSL but I'm going to actually do this
drop down menu to go to the bow.net to
see the one that we just added
and you can see it's installing it says
it may take up to an hour but then after
that we can go to the website instead of
going to http colon slash slash bo.net
it'll be https colon slash slash bo.net
because it has SSL it's the the S stands
for secure I'll go back to the dashboard
now I want to get WordPress installed on
the website many different website
hosting Services allow you to easily
install WordPress on the website so the
exact method could be different if
you're not using hostinger but it should
be relatively similar so I'm just going
to scroll down on this page here and I'm
going to click WordPress
and then I'm going to install WordPress
and I'll fill this out to finish setting
up so we'll just call it my website for
now and anything here can be changed
later and then I'll put in the password
[Music]
and then I'll just use these default
settings here and click install
we're on the hosting or dashboard but we
want to go to the WordPress dashboard so
we can start creating our WordPress
website so I'll just click on edit
website if you're using something
besides beside WordPress there'll be
something similar to get into the
WordPress dashboard
another way you can always access your
WordPress dashboard if you look in the
URL bar here we have the URL name and
then it's slash
wp-admin you can always go to slash
wp-admin to get to your WordPress
dashboard
okay I've zoomed in a little bit on this
and we're just going to look at some of
the things on the menu over here these
are all things that are important when
creating a WordPress page we have our
posts when we're going to create a new
post but you're likely going to be
creating a new page like the about us
page contact page and stuff like that
and you can also change your appearance
and there's just a bunch of other
sections here many of which will be
going over in more detail later in this
tutorial but first of all let's go over
to users and you just want to make sure
that you have a a password we just want
to make sure that the password is the
password we chose now depending on how
you installed WordPress you may not have
created a password and depending on what
hosting provider you use and you want to
maybe verify that you're not going to
have a default password so I'm just
going to type in a password Here
and then I'm going to do update profile
okay now we're going to go to the
plugins tab
before we deal with the plugins let's
just get rid of some of these tabs I'm
going to click X here we don't need this
I guess they're not tabs they're just
information boxes and to get rid of this
one we're going to go through and
actually delete some of the extra
plugins here we don't a lot of these
plugins we don't actually need
so I've selected all the extra plugins
and I don't need this one either and I'm
going to go to
oh first I'll do deactivate
and then I'll just select them again and
I'm going to go to delete
and don't worry if you accidentally
deleted plugin that you actually need
because it's really easy to reinstall
them so I'm going to go to delete
okay and now we've deleted all the
plugins we don't need and you can see we
no longer have the extra information box
up here those associated with a
particular Pro plugin now no matter what
type of website you're trying to make
you're probably going to want to install
a theme and that's what we're going to
do themes make it way easier to create
the website that you want to create and
a lot of themes comes with various
templates so one theme can have multiple
templates and each template can be for a
different types of type of website now
what you're going to want to do is go to
add new and there's tons of different
type different themes that you can
install one of the most popular ones is
Astra so just go up here and search for
Astra and Astra comes with a lot of
different templates you can use so it's
basically one theme that has one way of
kind of modifying and editing it but
there's all these templates for
different types of websites including
blogs we're creating a tech blog and let
me show you how we can get that set up
with Astro pretty much everything I'm
going to teach you will work with will
apply to any theme that you choose so if
you choose a different theme it's still
you're still going to be able to do most
of the things that I'm showing you so
I'm going to go with Astra and I already
have it installed so you're going to
have to install it and then you're going
to have to activate it I'm just going to
click activate here and then once it's
activated we can just go to get started
but you can see right here it has comes
with dozens of radio starter templates
so that's what we're going to be using
so I'll click get started
foreign
we don't need to watch the video here
build your website now and then it's
going to say select your page builder a
page builder is just something that you
can use to create your page to modify it
and to make changes on it so block
editor this is the default editor that
comes with WordPress and Elementor and
beaver Builder are third-party editors
but they're both very popular and if we
click if we choose one of these we can
still also use this one because it's
still built into WordPress so I'm going
to go with Elementor that's one of the
most popular ones and that's going to
make it even easier to edit our website
and making it make it look exactly how
we want it to look and so pretty much
all these themes all these templates off
they all often have free versions and
paid versions they're trying to make
some money so so they're gonna give you
the free versions to get you to install
it but then you may see a paid version
that you want to upgrade but in in this
course we're only using free versions
and you can do quite a bit with free
versions so these are all these
templates that you can choose from and
you can see if it says premium that's
obviously one of the paid ones but
there's quite a few of the free versions
so you can see these are all different
ones and what you want to do is find
something that looks close to what you
want or somewhat similar and you can do
a considerable amount of customizing so
it doesn't have to look exactly like
what you want but find one that's kind
of the closest and then you can go
through and basically customize every
single part of it so it it perfectly
fits what you're trying to do with your
website since we're going to go with a
since we're creating a tech blog I'm
going to use this creative blog so I'm
going to just click on here and then we
can upload a logo but look what it says
don't have a logo no problem you can
upload it later so that's true for in
this initial customization that we're
going to be do it be doing everything
you can do later so you don't have to do
it now you can always change things
anything that you do you can always
change back so I'll Skip and continue
and then we can change the color so see
whenever we click that we can see
different things on the page turn if we
go down here we can see more more things
changing colors you can see if we go
down here see different things are going
to change color so I kind of like this
green one so we're going to go with that
one and then we can choose what font we
want and if we go back up here we can
kind of see the heading I'm going to go
with this one I kind of like the the
different uh small like the curved
serifs that are on the letters there so
we're going to continue
and then we can tell a little bit about
yourself but I don't want to I'm not
going to tell anything about myself and
so we can choose oh wait I meant to not
agree to receive anything and so uh you
can basically leave all these checked
but I'm not going to share sensitive
data but we'll import what all these
things are going to help the theme work
so uh submit and build my website
okay now we just have to wait and you
can see it says installing required
theme plugins and forums
so we could install the themes and the
forums individual individually but this
is what's going to do it all for us so
to do all the ones that we need to to
make our template work
congratulations our website is ready so
I'm going to go to view your website
and now we can see what the website
looks like this is basically the default
website we see that we have the title
the logo up here and there's this menu
here we can do a search and we can
subscribe and so if we scroll down here
we can see we can subscribe to a
newsletter there's basically an uh ad
here which is just a sample ad which
we're definitely going to remove and so
we have different categories of the
articles that are that are on this
website and some podcasts now these
aren't any you won't play anything
because this is just kind of an example
of what it could look like if you have
podcasts and then we have this bottom
menu here and some Social Links and you
can install or subscribe down here and
then if we go here these are all
different categories of Articles so
articles about film articles about
advertising articles about photography
see if I scroll down we see that's one
article and then here's another article
so each article has a picture headline
and I can click into that and then we
can read the full article and this is
just dummy text Lauren ipsum uh it's not
going to so this is just like an example
of what an article would look like and
then there's related posts and you can
leave a comment
so we're going to focus on building a
Blog
but like I said everything that we're
doing will apply to pretty much any type
of website you're creating so if you
want to create a
so if you want to create a business page
or a portfolio page or any type of
website you'll be able to follow along
and apply a lot of these same Concepts
to any type of website
so if I go to full screen mode we can
see that when we're on the website it
just says my website right here well we
wanted to say something different so
that's the first thing we're going to
customize we're going to say how to
customize a bunch of stuff but the first
thing is just going to be the title up
here oh yeah I don't need this tab open
this is the tab where it installed
everything so I'll close that so let me
go back to Wordpress and we'll full
screen that again I'll go to settings
general settings and then here is where
we can change the site title and tagline
and whenever you install templates every
once in a while it's going to
um
pop up different things like this we can
just close that so I'm going to call
this the site title this is a tech blog
so we're going to call it Tech tuba and
then for the tagline we'll say all the
best tech news I could just select it
because I had already typed that in
earlier so then you can also change all
these other things you never want to
change the url but you can change the
administration email you can change the
site language time zone date format so
these are all things you can customize
I'll just click save changes we're just
going to click change the title
and so now if I open up the website
and then we can see right here Tech tuba
all the best tech news okay before we
start customizing this further I'm going
to go back over to Wordpress and I'm
going to go over to the plugins so I
talked to you about how some plugins
were installed automatically you can see
these blue rows here are the ones that
were just installed with Elementor
that's to help us edit the page in a
more easily in the easy way start our
templates that gives us access to all
the different starter sites and we chose
we chose one from there WP Forum this is
going to make it so we can easily get
our contact form to work
okay so let's go back to our page so we
already looked at all these different
things so now we're going to start
actually customizing it so there's a few
different ways you can start customizing
so we're first going to click on
customize right here first of all you
can see it says more options available
in Astra Pro so like I said there's a
few different things where they try to
upsell you but we don't need any of
those extra options you get quite a bit
of options just in the free version so
you can change the theme which we're not
going to do but if we go to Global and
we go to Colors this is where we can
change the colors when we were setting
up the theme we chose some colors but if
you want to make some changes you can do
it here like for instance I can for
Global one I can change to red and you
can see right here that button changed
to red and then if you ever decide oh I
don't want that
um and instead of clicking publish
publish is going to save what you just
chose I can just hit X and then it's
going to say the changes will be lost so
I'm going to make those changes lost and
now it goes back to green we're now
going to go back to customize so we'll
go back over to there and to Global we
can also change the typography so this
will change what the different what kind
of fonts we're using and then you can
change the fonts for different elements
on the page like different headings and
there's just a bunch of different things
that we can change so we can change the
the layout we can change what buttons
are going to look like like it can make
it so it's the buttons are going to be
um kind of white like that
I can change some padding border width
of of the buttons like like maybe I want
to have uh 10 for the Border width so
you can see these buttons just got a lot
bigger because the width of around the
Border got bigger but I'm going to
change that back to zero and then we'll
go back here
um
you can also change the header uh
breadcrumb blog we're gonna be going
through some of these later but one
thing I want to focus on right now is
the site identity this is where you can
actually add a an icon that's going to
appear in the URL bar and then you can
also add a logo so right now there's the
this logo the creative room 80. and you
can see we have the normal logo and the
retina logo the difference is the type
of screen so retina screens are
generally generally screens that have
more pixels per inch so you need a
higher resolution logo now you can use
the same logo for both but also you have
the option to put a higher resolution
logo for the retina logo
and you can see while we're on this page
you can see this other menu has appeared
down here and it's basically showing all
the different
um the the different pieces of content
that are above the main content so we
have this is the main content here but
this is showing at the very top we have
the site title and Logo which are right
here and then this line right here is
this line where we have the primary menu
which it does it is putting the menu
down to the second line here which uh
I'll show you how to fix that later and
then we also have the search and the
button that's what we have right there
and then there's there's nothing in this
third we could add so if we wanted to
add something and then like an
additional menu or something that was at
the top of every page we could but right
now let's do the logo
now there's a lot of websites out there
that can help you create a logo for free
and then there's different websites out
there where you can hire people to
create logos such as Fiverr but I just
went ahead and created a logo myself so
I'm going to change logo and then I can
either drop files or select a file
so I'm just going to drop this file here
and
we just uploaded the logo and then for
the alt text now the alt text is helpful
for well for one if people can't see the
image then they can or they're able to
read the alt text and also if the image
doesn't load correctly it will it will
be able to show the alt text so it's
good to have an ALT text for all your
images so I'll do Tech tuba logo
and then I will
select
okay oh now I can um I can crop it I'm
going to crop it so it just uses the
entire image and then click crop image
or I guess I could have clicked skip
cropping since I'm not cropping and so
I'm gonna have to upload it in two spots
I'm going to upload it here and then I'm
just going to upload the same one for
the retina logo so just go there and
choose image okay so now it shows Tech
tuba now
um it's a little bigger than I was
wanting it to be so let's see how we can
change the size of the logo
so to change the size of the logo I'm
going to go down here and then we can
set the the logo width we can also set a
few different things like the site title
and this tagline but I'm going to go to
the width and I'm going to just
um set a specific width so before if you
don't have anything here it's just going
to basically be the default so if I just
delete that
um or if I like no you put 0 if you put
zero it will put the default size but I
am going to make it smaller so I'm going
to set a specific size now this so some
of the design decisions I'm creating I'm
doing may not look the best but you can
kind of keep tweaking things until
things look exactly how you want it to
look so I've already noticed that we
have the blue here so it'd be kind of
nice maybe if the buttons were the same
as shade of blue which we can do I
already showed you how to change that
color for now though we'll just we'll
just move on to the next part of our
website
so now I'm going to go back
and for now I'm gonna I'm not gonna do
anything more we're gonna actually come
back to some of these later if you want
to go through and just check them out
yourself you can we're going to come
back to some of these later so right now
I'm just going to click the word the
publish button
and then now that's published I can hit
the X here
okay and
you know now that I'm seeing it yeah I
am going to go and change the colors so
it matches that the logo that we just
got so we'll go back to customize and
then
Global colors I'll just change these
greens to Blues so I'm going to change
that this to and if I can
basically get something kind of close to
what's in the image
in the the logo that we developed so
let's do
that's a good color for that one and
then here we're going to do a darker
blue for that
okay so you can see we have dark blue
and light blue okay it looks good and so
we'll publish that
okay so now I'm gonna go and continue to
make some changes here
so let's start customizing this page
we'll first work on customizing this
home page and then we'll look about how
to customize the other sections of the
page including the blog entries first
we're going to go to edit with Elementor
if we go to edit page we'll use the
WordPress built-in editor but Elementor
makes some things a little easier when
you're editing so I'm going to click
edit with Elementor and then we got this
open you can see we have the Elementor
side panel and then we have the
Navigator over here I'm going to pull
this to the side and make the Navigator
go all the way to the side and we can
still kind of scroll back and forth to
see their whole page and the cool thing
about the Navigator I'll talk about that
before I go to this menu over here the
Navigator is going to show all the
elements in the page so we have if we
just open these drop down menus we have
this heading which is this one see right
here the image box which is right here
and then we have a button we got see
when we click on it it will kind of
highlight it so that image is this image
down here and then we have another
column which is this image right here so
uh basically in this section there are
two columns the left column and the
right column and then we can scroll down
here and actually if I zoom out a little
bit here we'll be able to see a little
more on the page at once so we come down
I'm going to look at the next section
and the next section just has one column
it has this image box and then it has
this form and then we have the final
section which just has one column which
has image which is this add here the
heading but so so I'm not going to go
through the rest of them but you can
kind of see you can see how it can make
it easier to select one specific part of
your page you can see as we move our
Mouse around it we can
each element or each section on the page
will have this little edit but button so
what I'm going to do for now is just
close this Navigator we're not going to
use the Navigator I'm going to close it
so it makes things easier to see on the
page so let's start doing some editing
to the page so I'm going to click right
into here I can click if I click this
edit button it will bring up our edit
section over here and you can see this
just happens to be an image box and the
image so you can have a text box or an
image box
so this image box just happens to not
have an image with it but it does have a
title and a description so I can
actually change I can actually change it
right on the page like this
best
Tech
news or I can I can change it right over
here I can say
your
One Stop page for all the latest
Tech news
and so we can go through and basically
click each element and make some changes
so this read article well let me go to
this read article button so if we go to
the button we can we can change the text
of the button I can say
Go to stories
so it will go to specific stories we can
change the the type of button which is
this is just going to basically
be different colors of the button you
can see
we'll just go back to the default but
specifically I'm going to look at the
link right now this button doesn't
actually do anything if you have a link
and it just has the this uh pound sign
or hash mark hashtag here that just
means it's an empty link it's a link
that doesn't go anywhere but we want to
go somewhere
so what I'm going to do is make it go to
the film page and so if I hover over the
film page you can see that the bottom
left hand corner of the screen you can
see the URL for the film page and we're
going to just make it say that URL or I
can just go to copy link address and
then I can just put the link right here
so now when we click the Go to stories
page it'll go directly to this category
and we can also do other things like we
can change the alignment of the button
we can change the size of the button we
can change the spacing and then you can
also open up these link options and you
can choose is this button going to open
up is this link going to open up into a
new window there's a bunch of up options
you can do for a button now let's go
over here I'm going to go over to this
image right here and I'm going to change
this image so if I go to choose image
now for some reason these tabs aren't
showing but see if I hover you can see
here's where you upload a file or here
it says free images I'm not quite sure
hopefully on your com you're just not
being hidden like that but if I go to
free images we can see this is powered
by pixabay now pixabay is just a way is
a is a website where you can get free
royalty free images so I'm going to
search for technology
and then I'm actually going to change
the orientation to do a vertical
orientation because I think that will
work better in that spot oh I guess it's
not having any for vertical orientation
okay so now if I just search for Tech we
can get this vertical orientation
and I like this one because it has a lot
of technology in it um it's really about
broadcasting now you can go through and
find images in another place and upload
it but for now I'm just going to throw
in this image right here
and insert media
okay so now we have this
me this image that we've put into our
website and we can also change other
things like right here this is also an
image right here I'm going to keep it
here we'll just we're just gonna go down
and see this subscribe to our newsletter
and I can go through and change this and
say you will get
the best articles to your inbox
and then you can see we can put in your
email address and subscribe and later
we'll get we'll I'll show you how to set
this up so it it works even better so
we're gonna go we're going to show how
to use this subscribe form and the
contact form so I'll show you that later
now we don't want to have ads on our
page so I'm going to show you how to
just remove this section completely so
what I'm going to do to delete this
section I could click click this x
button but that's going to click delete
this whole section including the podcast
the categories and this ad here so to
delete just this ad basically I'm going
to select I'm going to right click and
then I'm going to go to delete it just
deletes that section so we I want to
keep the popular category section but
this is just a tech blog we don't have
podcasts so I'm going to delete this
podcast section also so I'm going to
right click go to delete and then here I
can actually just hit this x button and
it's going to delete that whole section
so we have the four different categories
so let's update our categories these
aren't the categories we're going to
have we're going to have a category
called news
we're going to have a category called
reviews
and then we're going to have a category
called gaming
and then we're going to have a category
called software
okay now we can if we wanted to we can
actually right click and delete just one
of these buttons one of these categories
or we could even add new categories if
we want to add a new one I could
actually right click on this and go to
duplicate and so now there's a five here
instead of four but I'm going to just
delete that because we we only want the
four here and then if I can delete
another one to go to three so now we
have these these four different
categories and let's just choose new
images so for news
I'm going to go to edit I did a right
click edit column
and then in style this is where I can
change the image
so I'm going to click choose image I'm
just going to basically choose some
images that are already in there to make
that faster for reviews I'll go to
choose image and we'll use this image
and then for review they go to edit
column again Style
then I'll use this for the reviews and
then for a gaming I am going to go to
style and then we could go to the free
images and select one but to make it
quicker I'm just going to select an
image that's already on here so this
person's not quite playing a game but
we're just going to use that one and
then
I'll just choose another one really
quick for software and we'll do that one
so now we've kind of we've learned how
to edit this but let's see how we can
add a new column so what if we want
something after the categories what if
we want something else well there's a
few different ways to do it if we want
to in between we can press this plus
button but I'm but if we want this at
the end it's already it's always going
to show you it's always going to have
one at the end that you can add so I can
click this and then we can select the
structure you can see these there's
different column layouts we can choose
and so I'll click that so now we're
going to have we can see it right here
so we have the small column here and the
larger column here if I click here now
it's going to show us all these
different elements we can add so we may
want to have a heading so I can drag
this heading here and then we can edit
the cutting we can change the the the
size we can change the style we can also
go back to the elements here then I can
add some text right underneath here so
we can have heading here and it's also
cool how easy it is to add a video we
can click the plus button here if you
don't already have the elements section
up here and I can bring in a video and
once you bring in the video then we can
just put in a specific URL so I'm just
going to paste in a URL here and so this
is a good Tech related video how to
build a Hackintosh and you can even
specify the start time in time whether
you want to auto play no because
everyone hates Auto playing and then
there's a bunch of other options that
you can you can choose player controls
if you want we'll turn off the controls
so there's a bunch of things you can do
we want to turn on privacy mode that's
something you probably want to do
because then it's not going to attract
people
and so then when you go to your website
people can have this video here so
there's a bunch of different things you
can you can edit you can kind of go
around and change different things but
let's go over to I want to show you how
to update these blog sections or or the
article sections uh later we're going to
talk about how to update all the stuff
down here so we have different uh
choices we have the film advertising
photography digital and we got rid of
podcasts so let's make it so this is all
updated if we click here you'll notice
that if see if I move my mouse around
you can see wherever my mouse is there's
a blue box around but there's no blue
box round over here because this menu we
have to edit in a separate spot of of
Wordpress we don't we don't edit this
menu through Elementor so uh first of
all let's take a note of the things news
reviews gaming and software that's what
we're gonna change this menu to and what
I'm going to do is Click update to save
all the changes we had from before now
we're going to go out of Elementor I'm
going to click this hamburger menu and
then I'm just going to go to view page
okay so we can see the page with all the
updates we made you can see this gets a
little maybe too long we can go up so
that's something we can actually edit so
this image doesn't go down so far but we
can see it has these changes we've have
this whole new section here so let's see
how to update that menu we're gonna have
to go back into the WordPress dashboard
so I'm going to hover over appearance
and then I'm going to go to menus
and here is where I'm going to update
that top menu you can see all these
different options so we're not going to
have podcast so I'm just going to click
this
and go to the drop down menu and then
remove and then I'm also going to get
rid of this one
because we really only want four items
and then now we have to rename so to
rename these we're actually going to
change the categories so first of all
I'm going to save that
and it says menu has been updated and
then let's change the category names
so change the category names we'll go to
posts
um so these are all default posts that
are just kind of uh brought in based on
our theme and then I'm going to go to
categories so here's all the categories
and this is the one we deleted so I'm
going to delete that one digital and now
I'm going to change the name of these
other four so advertising I'm going to
change to news and then I'll the slug
this is what's going to be in the URL I
still have to update it so it will go
into the URL so you do that later so
this is what the URL is going to look
like
and then we'll update that
go to categories and then we can go to
the next one
which will be the design one
oh and we can do the quick edit to make
it a little quicker and we'll do reviews
and then the film this is going to be
gaming
and then software
so most types of blogs you're going to
have different categories and so this is
how you update them
so if we go back to our our website and
I'm just going to refresh here we can
see it automatically updated these here
so review reviews gaming new software so
let's see how we can put that in a
different order so we want those to be
in the same order as our categories down
here so what I'm doing see basically I
have these two tabs over here so I'm
using shortcut keys to switch between
them so I'm going to go back over here
and then I can go back to appearance and
menus and now I can move these around so
the first thing is going to be news
reviews gaming software and after moving
around I can save that
and if I go back over here and refresh
news reviews gaming software so now yeah
now we have the different categories so
these different articles are in these
categories these are all the the sample
articles
so now that we learned how to make
different blog post categories let's see
how to customize what these these Pages
look like so this page is the page
that's going to show a little bit of
each article and then when you click
into the article that's where it's going
to show the full article so there's two
different things that we need to
customize you can see that there's no
edit with L Mentor because when we're on
editing this page we have to do it a
little differently so I'm going to click
customize
and then go to blog
and so there's two things here the blog
archive
which is basically this page here and
then we also have the single post which
is when you click into the post so the
blog archive I can change what this is
going to look like so like for instance
if I click here now it's going to uh
basically make it a little smaller and
then put the title here so we can kind
of just
experiment with
clicking some of these different layouts
so here before we didn't have a sidebar
but here we have a sidebar where we we
can if we want to sidebar with some
extra information we can add that so we
have a search here where we can search
for blog posts the recent posts recent
comments the archives and I kind of like
that I want people to be able to see
when they go to this page the I want
them to be able to search for things and
I want them to be able to to look see
the recent posts and we can also switch
what side of the side that's on
so if we keep scrolling down here we can
do different things like we can turn on
or off the features image so we want the
image to show up do we want the title
and metadata to show up
uh do we want the map of comments so
right now none of these have comments
but if I
take this off you can't even leave a
comment
and then we can turn on or off the
category so right now I see it says the
here's the comments the category and the
author so those are the things we can
turn off or on we can turn on the
publish date
and so there's just a bunch of things
you can do to change what your blog is
going to look like and you can even
change these so see where it says recent
post if I click this little edit button
here it's going to first of all I'm just
going to click got it and it's going to
come into here and now I can change what
this is going to look like so instead of
saying recent posts I can say maybe
recent articles
now it's going to say recent articles
and then I can even maybe if I highlight
that I can make it bold
I guess that's not doing anything but I
can make it a talent italic and there's
all sorts of things you can change
and that can change this stuff here like
maybe I don't want the recent comments
so let's if I don't want this I can if I
don't want the recent comments I can
click on these three little blocks here
these three little dots and I can say
remove group and what if I want the
archives above
I can click here and I can move the
archives above or I can move the
archives below and you can just uh play
around with this and get it to look
exactly how you want it to look
so I'm gonna now I'm going to go into
the actual uh blog post so if I go into
here
and now now we want to edit this blog
post so I'm going to blog and single
post so now there's a lot of other
things we can do once we're in here do
we want to use the box layout full width
layout so you can kind of
try different things about what exact
what the the layout you want for each
individual blog post you can change the
the custom width the content width and
then you can check check whether it's
going to show the featured image
basically all the same information
before you can put on here and we can
change how many related posts for any
space right now there's only one but we
can say how many related posts we want
to show up right here okay now I'm going
to save the changes that I made to that
so I'll hit publish
so now that we know how to modify this
and and change what the blog looks like
how do you actually add new blog entries
well it's simple so I'm going to hit X
here and I'm going to go back into
WordPress so there's a few ways to add a
new post I can either hover into posts
I'm going to add new or I can hover over
this new at the top go to post there's a
bunch of things you can add so I'll go
to new post
and I will create a new article
website offers free
developer curriculum
so I'm just going to start typing in
here
you can learn to code for free
at free codecamp.org
it's a great website
and then I can add something else so I
can click this plus button here and I
can add a gallery which is makes it so
you can see multiple images and switch
between them or a quote or an image I'll
go to image and I'll go to the media
library and we'll just add these this
milk here so we have this text and then
we have this image here and then I can
even change the size so if I go over to
the side it's going to give us some more
options so image size I'm going to do a
medium image and then if I go to
Advanced you can add title attributes
you can make a link here additional CSS
but what I'm also want to do is make
sure for this post I'm you can add a
bunch of other things in in your blog
post but what I'm going to do is make
sure I assign it to a specific category
this is going to be in the news category
I also want to make sure I add a
featured image this is the image that
will appear at the very top of the
article so the featured image is not an
image from the article you have to add
another image so I'm going to click show
featured image and I'm going to go to
upload files
and I'm just going to drag a file in
here
and again I am going to add an ALT text
free code Camp website
and then I'll set it as the featured
image which is just a screenshot of the
free cocam website
and there's a few other things you can
do like
we can change excerpt this is optional
but if you want to basically like a
summary of the article that's going to
appear on when it's showing the list of
all articles this would be the excerpt
that's going to show up and you can also
set tags so tags are going to be
different than categories and it's just
another way to change it's just another
way to sort your articles so I could say
websites
and then it says separate the with the
commas or the enter keys so what we can
now search uh now we can now add this
tag to the article okay now I can click
publish to publish the article
and then I can even click View Post
right here so here's the Post website
offers free developer curriculum and we
can see this is the main image and
here's the article and then we even have
some related posts and if I click on the
news page so here's one of the posts
here's the other post so we have three
different posts including the free code
Camp Post
and you can basically do that for
basically whatever category you add is
the category it's going to show up on
here okay that's basically all there is
to it to adding blog entries and
customizing blog entries let's look out
how to customize the about page and the
contact page so with the way you
customize this about page is going to be
just like we did the home page so if I
go to edit with Elementor and now we can
go through and and update things on here
like this thing right here we probably
don't even need that so I'll right click
and then I will delete and now we can go
through and and update this text
we are the most trusted
news source you can go through and just
update this as much as you as you want
and we can delete a section like this
this looks like it's supposed to be like
an ad or something well I want to change
that image we don't want to use an ad
image I'll just change it to this one
right here so now you can go through and
basically you can change as much as you
want see anywhere you click in you can
just go through and start editing so
it's pretty straightforward it's kind of
so I'm not going to go through and
change all these things but when we go
to the contact page it's going to be a
little different
actually refresh the page but I didn't
click update so it didn't save this but
that's okay you know how to do it so
we're going to just look at how to
update the contact page because that's
going to be a little different but uh
and sometimes when you're in Elementor
to get to another page you're first
going to have to go out of Elementor and
then you can go back into it so I'm just
going to go to view page go into contact
and then I'll go to edit with Elementor
again and so you can a lot of this stuff
you can edit just like you did before
like for this company information
instead of having an address I'm going
to get rid of that and I'm going to say
bow at
freakodecamp.org so I'm just going to
put an email address and then I can
actually make this a clickable email
address I'll to uh to make to make an
email address that you can click on and
it opens your default via editor you can
type in a link just like this you mail
to and put a colon and then just put the
email address and then this time I am
going to put update
but if I click here
we can see no matter where I click
um this is actually just becoming a form
there's no way to change on this form
there's no way to change what this set
Coss first name last name email address
there's no way to change on here what
that looks like so to actually change
the form there's something else we have
to do so what I'm going to do is go to
set I'm going to go out of Elementor I'm
going to go to view page and then I'm
going to go to WP forms WP forms is
where you're going to make edits to the
form and we have a newsletter signup
form and we have a contact form one of
the newsletter sign up form was on the
main page also I think it's at the
bottom here too see here's the
newsletter sign up form and then here's
the contact form so I'm going to go to
edit form
okay so here's how we can edit a form so
we have the first name last name email
address message what if we want
something else so I can actually add a
different another thing to this form so
I'm going to go to add fields and you
can see we have a lot of different
choices what I'm going to add is a drop
down so I'm just going to drag it in and
now if I click it says click to edit if
I click here I can now change this so
um how did you hear about us
and you can say
search engine
advertisement
Word of Mouth
and we can set this to require if we
want and see when we hit required it'll
put that asterisk and then you won't be
able to submit the form unless it's
filled out but we won't make this
required so we just added that to the
form
and see how this has two as first name
and last name well if I go here I'm
going to go to simple so now it's only
going to have one field so we basically
can do first minute last first last or
simple which is just it's just going to
have one blank for the name so that's
what we want so we want the one blank
for the name and and then we want the
email address how did you hear a bus and
message and it's set up so when you
click submit it's going to automatically
submit the email to whatever email
address you have as your administrator
email on WordPress so it's automatically
going to just send an email right to
your email address and there's a bunch
of other things you can do on this
a bunch of different other types of
fields you can use like these ones I
think you have to get the the paid
version but this is just going to be
just enough this but just these fields
are going to be uh pretty good so I'm
going to save this and if I put X on
here and then I'm going to go back to
two on my side and go back to the
contact form and now we can see this so
the name field now just gives us one one
box here I guess it doesn't say name in
there anymore so let's let's we probably
want to change that but we have the
email address now we can choose from
this drop down box really quick let's
see how we can change that to actually
show that that's the name field so I'm
going to go to edit again the contact
form go to the name field
and then under Advanced I can
put what the placeholder is so the
placeholder is what's going to show up
in there until someone types in
something so I'll just type in name and
then default value would be so then this
placeholder is going to be like the
grayed out text a default value would be
an actual entry that would automatically
be in there so I'm going to save that
and we will go back to the page and now
yeah so I can click here and I can just
select my name here and you can see it
so when nothing was in there we had the
placeholder where it says name here oh
the field is required and then so I can
type in that
hello and then I'll just click submit
and it should submit that form
and see when I submit it says thanks for
contacting us we will be with you
shortly well that's another thing that
you set up in WP forums let me go back
to the contact page like that I'll go to
contact form edit form and if I go to
settings and then confirmations thanks
for contacting us we'll be in touch with
you shortly so this is where you would
change what's going to show on the page
once someone fills out the form
now if you go through and test out your
form and it doesn't work let me show you
how you can fix that so we're going to
go go to settings uh notifications and
if you see right here it says the
current from email address does not
match your website domain name this can
cause your notification notification
emails to be blocked or marked as spam
so right now it's sending to the add an
email which is definitely what I want
but it's coming from add an email but we
don't want it to come from admin email
it's showing right here you may want to
it says try using a form address that
matches your website domain and then it
gives an a suggestion which I'm just
going to use this so I'm going to make
it come come from no reply at bow.net
and then we can also change this so this
is going to be called
um Tech tuba and then we can even change
the email subject line that comes in so
I'll put new entry
Tech
tuba
and now I can
just check all these other things and
this looks good
so I'm going to save this
okay now I'm going to test out the form
again now we could test it on the page
like we did before but I can also just
test it here but I can also test it by
just clicking this preview button here
and now
um it's the contact form preview so it's
not really on the contact page but it's
the exact same form and I can I'm just
going to test to make sure it works
does
my form work okay you always want to
make sure it works before before you
launch your website because you want to
make sure that people try to contact you
it actually just does actually come in
and I went to my email and I actually
had to go to my spam folder so I'm gonna
go to my spam folder here and then you
can see it it came in and I'm going to
do report not spam so hopefully next
time it won't go to my spam folder now
we've already learned how to update a
lot of parts of our website but let's do
a few more things you can see when I
click reviews if you look at the URL
here that's not a really a good URL cat
equals three we want this to say reviews
here so it and then if I click on actual
article it just says P equals 39 that's
not the type of URL that we want and
it's not really search engine optimized
so I'm going to go back over to my
dashboard then I'm going to go to
settings and then I'm going to go to
permalinks so this is where we change
what the link is going to look like and
right now we have it on plane that's the
default and that's basically the worst
thing that you don't you don't want
plain personally I think the best thing
is just to use post name so this is
going to be a lot more readable URL and
so it's not just going to be like P
equals 123 it's going to be the actual
name of the post so I'm going to click
save changes
and then I'm just going to refresh here
and now if I go to reviews we can see
category reviews well that's all I want
go here category gaming if I click on a
actual article you can see actually the
the article now this is just some sample
text here for the article name but if we
go let's go to the article that that we
wrote here if I click here website
offers free developer curriculum that
looks pretty good that looks a lot
better but let me show you how you would
if you didn't like this URL let me show
you how you would change that if I go to
edit post here I can actually edit the
post but I can also edit the URL
so I just click right into the URL here
and website offers free instead of
website offers free developer curriculum
I'm going to say free code camp
okay now update
and then we will I'll go to preview
and preview new tab and now we can see
oh actually we don't really want the
preview we want the actual one so let me
go to news and this free cocamp offers
free developer curriculum great that's
the exact type of URL we want now I want
to talk to you more about making your
website responsive
what I'm going to do is go and I'm going
to go actually back to the home page
here I just click this link here or the
the the the logo to go back to the home
page and I'm going to go back to edit
with Elementor now we're going to talk
about how to make sure it looks good
whether it's on a desktop a tablet or a
mobile device if we come down here to
the bottom left corner and it says
responsive mode if I click this now we
can see this new menu at the top here
I'm going to go back to full screen and
we can see this is desktop mode tablet
mode or mobile so I'm going to click on
mobile now it's showing what this is
going to look like on mobile and we can
actually make changes like so far this
looks pretty good but we can actually
make changes to what it's going to look
like only on mobile so I'm going to
click here
and this I want this to be centered but
only on mobile so I'm going to click on
style and then
okay then content and then I'm going to
click the centered button
and then you can see see how there's
this little mobile icon that's how we
know it's only being centered when it's
on mobile so I can click update now let
me switch between so on the not mobile
on desktop we can see this is left
aligned but if I switch back to mobile
we can see that it's centered so that
makes it it's and then we can also see
we have this hamburger menu here
that's gonna look a lot better on mobile
and so that's just a nice way to test
what your website is going to look on
for different aspect ratios and
different types of devices so that looks
pretty good and then you can always make
changes that are specific to one type of
device or aspect ratio just how I showed
you
okay I'm gonna go out of this and now
we're going to look at how we can update
this footer here so everything down here
we can't just we can't just edit with
Elementor let me actually let me go back
into Elementor there's no way to see if
I if I move my mouse around here
nothing's really highlighting as the
different sections so to modify the
footer we're going to have to go there's
a few different ways to get into the
method where you modify the footer but
I'm going to go into customize and then
once I'm into customize a header Builder
is how you update what the header is
going to look like see we have the menu
here the search the button so if I just
uh if we like this subscribe button well
that's really not helpful here because
we already have the surprise the
Subscribe form another place so I can
just remove that so subscribe button and
the same thing with the header I'm gonna
go or the same thing with the footer I'm
gonna go to footer Builder and the
footer Builder we can see there's three
different sections of the footer so this
top section with the menu that's right
here the social icons right here then we
have this HTML that's basically this
text right here this widget which is
this subscribe form and the copyright
form at the bottom so if I click on any
one of those things you can see it's
going to change what's in the side menu
so the footer menu I'm going to keep
that basically the same but the social
icons this is where I can update the
links for the social icons or just take
some away like we're probably not going
to want Facebook but for uh YouTube I
can just type in the YouTube You Are URL
so https colon slash less youtube.com
free
code camp and then or we can
update the the Twitter URL so https
colon slash slash Twitter
.com free code camp and then we could
also change what the icons is going to
look like so uh basically I want the
icon but let's say we want to add a new
a new thing so I can basically we can we
can click any of these uh and just to
add social icon it's going to look like
a little phone here but I can change the
icon and there's a bunch of icons
available so it can just kind of go
through these Pages or I can search the
icon I'm going to make it this bacterium
so if I click on that bacterium
now we have a we should be able to have
a bacterium a bacterium icon
but I don't really want that so I'm
going to go out of that and I'm
basically we're just going to have two
here Twitter and YouTube
and then I can also change this right
here so instead of sign up to receive
email updates fresh news and more I'll
just say sign up to receive
news
this but this little form here you edit
just with that WP form so the same way
we updated the contact form you can
update this with this one little this
really small form here but then we can
also update the the copyright so we can
say copyright we can so when it says
copyright in these uh these brackets
here that's the copyright sign current
year site title anytime there's the
brackets that we're doing something
Dynamic here this I type and then
powered by site title or we can put
created by you can see it's going to
update right there okay now I'm just
gonna publish that
okay great so now we learn how to update
all the stuff in the footer
and this is looking pretty good I mean
it's not like professionally designed or
anything but we're learning we've
learned how to update pretty much
everything in this blog now let's learn
how to make one more type of page so we
know how to make the blog entries and we
know how to edit the list of blog
entries here but there's this other type
the about so this about page is a page
and let's say you want another just
informational page you don't want to be
a Blog you want to just be some sort of
other piece of information that we can
put on our websites
let's say that you want to offer
consulting services and you want to give
people information about how they can
learn more about that well let me show
you how you would do that let's go back
to our administrator page and I'm going
to go to where it says pages so first
I'll just click here we can see all the
current Pages we can see that we have
the about contact home and then we have
some pages that we're not using like
we're not using the podcast page so
right now I'm just going to delete this
I'm going to click that and then just
click trash or it could just click trash
actually selecting it is so you can do a
bulk action but let's create a new page
and then we'll add it to our top menu so
I'm going to go over to the topper says
add new but first something I'm just
going to close that and then we'll add a
new page
and I will just call it Consulting
and you can just uh call whatever you
want and now we're going to edit it
basically very similar to how you edit a
blog post
I offer Consulting
Services if you want to schedule a
meeting
click the link below
and now I'm going to add a
button
contact me
and then I can just do contact if I if I
just type start typing contact it will
it will do a search for the different
page we already have so I can make this
uh contact me button go to the contact
page so you can obviously add different
images you can design this how you want
like I could click this plus button a
plus thing and then add a gallery where
we can just choose a few different
images for the gallery actually this one
I will choose the people
so we can choose all these images for a
gallery and you then do create new
gallery and you can even adjust the
order of the images in the gallery okay
so now let's just see what this looks
like so I can before I can publish it I
can also change the url
um right now it's on auto draft I'm
gonna so you can see it's eventually
going to be Consulting that's going to
be the Prima link which which is what we
want you can change the url if you want
and I will just click publish
and then just click publish again and
now I can view the page and here's our
page Consulting and I offer Consulting
service we have the contact me which
goes to the contact page but we can go
back and this uh doesn't really look
that good but you can kind of get the
idea of where you can just add different
pictures you can design it exactly how
you want so let's see how to add the
Consulting page to this top menu well
it's similar to when we were adjusting
what links were up here and we can just
do the same thing with our Consulting
page
so I'm going to go back to Wordpress
dashboard and then I'm going to go to
appearance and menus and now we can add
a new section so basically I can click
here where it says Consulting and so
these are all the things that aren't
currently in the menu well I guess some
of them are on the menu but I'll click
Consulting and do add to menu
and then I can just reorder it I'm going
to put it right before about and then if
we go to save menu and now I can open
the page again and we can see that the
Consulting page so we have the the main
page views gaming
and Consulting okay we learned how to
add a page now let's talk about search
engine optimization let's go back to our
main our main dashboard so we are going
to install a special plugin that's going
to help our blog and our Pages show up
better in search engines so I'm going to
go to plugins and I'm going to go to add
new now I'm just going to search for one
called yoast SEO
y-o-a-s-t SEO now this is one of the
most popular SEO plugins you can see it
has five million active installations
this is another one popular one that's
all in one SEO but we're gonna go with
yoast SEO I'm going to install this and
it's going to help us better optimize
our WordPress site so after it's
installed I can just click activate
so we can see that our it says your site
is already easier to find in it for
search engine so it automatically does
does some things right away but we can
configure to make it even better so
so let's go down and there is this paid
version but we're just going to go with
the free version because you can get a
lot just with the free version so we'll
start stop we're starting the SEO data
optimization
and it's analyzing the site that we
don't even have that much on the site so
uh it can so it is good so it works if
you already have a bunch on this site it
will analyze it but if you have it and
then you create another bunch of a bunch
of blog posts after you've already
installed then it'll kind of work with
with your content as you create it so
I'll click continue
and does your site represent an
organization or a person I'll go with
person
and we'll just keep going on this
and then we can add information now you
don't have to put in all this
information but it helps us optimize the
metadata so now I'm just going to add
the Twitter so how about
twitter.com slash Bo cartons
and then save and continue
oh https colon slash slash there we go
now do we want to give them data from
the site well I'm just going to put no
don't track my site data I'm glad that
that's the default and we can sign up
for a newsletter I'm not going to do
that so save and continue
and now we can visit the SEO dashboard
so it's going to detect problems and
luckily we don't have any SEO problems
but let's go through and then we can
choose what features we want to want to
use so all these features
basically apply to when you're creating
a blog entry so a lot of things like the
SEO analysis the readability analysis a
lot of this is going to appear when
you're actually creating a blog post
so and these work for both new posts and
posts you already have so let me show
you how that works I'm going to go to
the posts and then we'll go to the
website offers free developer curriculum
and if we scroll down here we can see
there's a new section here yoast SEO
and then we have the Focus key phrase if
we click here it's going to show what
that is so it says you'll find a focus
keyframe input field for every page on
your site you can enter the keyword or
key phrase you like you'd like the page
to rank for in Google and then the Oco
will run a check on the Page's content
to see if search engines will recognize
that's what it's about so let's just see
how that works so for this we want to
get the phrase learn to code so I'm just
going to type in learn to code
and we'll get related key phrases
okay and I'm going to approve it for
this application
and now we can see our related key
phrases so I typed in learn to code and
it's showing all these related ones
but now that we've put in this keyframe
so really key phrase would be other
phrases that kind of go along with that
so this will show us the volume of of
like how many searches are happening for
that key phrase so we can try to figure
out which key phrase should we optimize
for which key phrase should we put in
our title should we put in the body of
our our article and then so let's just
keep going down here and look at some of
these other things we can see the Google
preview what it's going to look like in
Google
and then we can see information from the
page and then look at this the SEO
analysis so this is going to give us
some information that we can improve on
have you evenly distributed your Focus
key phrase throughout the whole text
well no we because it was just like a
very quick article and we want to see
add some so these are all suggestions
add outbound links add internal links uh
make sure the key phrases in the SEO
title uh update the meta description
link that's this description here that
we can we can update that description
the text link that text only contains 13
words it's recommended to be 300 words
so it's going to give us all these
suggestions it gives us things that
we're doing good and we can go through
and this is going to give us some
information about how to make our
articles more SEO friendly
and then we can there's a bunch of other
things here uh but let's go to this next
tab readability so this is going to tell
us how readable our article is
and for the most part we have a lot of
um good results but that's just because
the article is pretty short so if you
have a longer article it will give you
more suggestions for how to improve the
readability
and here is where you can update the
schema now it says right here this helps
search engines understand your website
and your content
so this page default for folks this is a
blog post so we want to just keep it
that article type blog post so these are
generally going to be correct
automatically but if you want to change
this like this if this is the about page
or the fact page these are those are
going to be more specific for those
pages on the about page it's not going
to know it's the about page unless you
specify so that's basically how you can
use this SEO plugin to improve your SEO
okay and that's about it you now know
enough to create your own blog and to
start customizing it to meet your exact
needs we've reached the end of the
course good luck on making your own
WordPress website and remember to use
your code for good